the community still mourning the lives
lost in that terrible crash over the
weekend police tell us that the driver
of a dodge challenger traveling about
100 miles per hour before running a red
light up in north las vegas
nine people died as a result including
that driver and including children
now for some of those victims the effort
is now underway to help return their
remains to mexico the consulate of
mexico is now involved to help get that
done 8 news now reporter sally jeremiah
spoke to the mexican consulate and now
has more
as you may remember yesterday we spoke
to her linda sacaria she is the mother
of the children involved in the horrific
north las vegas crash yesterday she told
us she wanted to send her two-step
children back to mexico as they too have
families of their own today the mexican
consulate has been in touch to help them
during these difficult times this is the
first time in my 20 years
in this career that i have seen such a
tragedy i have spoken to them
presented our condolences
and share with them that we are here to
help council of mexico in las vegas
julian escutia says more than ever they
need the community to know there are
only one phone call away we are very
experienced in these processes
the paperwork that we conduct here at
the consulate is really really fast in
one day we issue the visas for the
remains to transit to mexico all of this
free of cost when the family have
financial need we do support them
escotia says they work with several
funeral homes that do offer affordable
prices he reminds the community to not
be ashamed or fearful for them asking
for documents or any other information
we can help them
to navigate the system because
oftentimes they don't don't have access
to
to funding to information then language
can be a barrier escutia is doing all he
can to help her linda zakarias i hope
that she
is a little bit relieved that she has
the backing and the support of her own
country as he says these tragedies are
preventable this should not happen
and not at all and should not happen
again now i'm told five of those seven
family members will be buried here in
las vegas if you would like to continue
helping the family we have posted that
gofundme page on our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting sally
jaramillo live local now